what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm Pat Hogue Pat the Canadian Hoda
filmmaker or some pretentious ass [ __ ]
on his Twitter Pat how do you feel being
here buddy
a little a little self-conscious at this
point but excited on the west grill I'm
so happy you're here we are partnered up
with loot gaming right now get your
freakin box today why haven't you done
it yet so much awesome stuff in here I
was supposed to unbox a box from awhile
ago that I didn't realize was blending
in with this black bin back here yeah so
like blending over there and I forgot
that the had the Box already so I got to
loot gaming boxes to unbox with guest
Patrick oh here
who's going to pull out the items for me
you're gonna be my hot female Price is
Right presenter today are you excited
for this yeah can I be more of the Deal
or No Deal girls who like open the yeah
they're hotter now let's start with this
one this is the first first one oh sorry
alright so one item at a time do not
show them to me all right you know what
you don't even look yourself why don't
you just reach in there feel around do
the t-shirt last this is my little
roulette meet on the box right side up
and there you turn it away here we go
you don't there you know there you go
he's lady go okay first item up for bid
he went with the shirt the one thing I
said do not bring out first I'm not rich
I was so focused on getting this aspect
right that's fine we got two boxes this
is your this is this is a trial works
like the first child run yeah seven more
items what's the net exactly it's like
the first child will do it right by the
second child that's why the younger
child can be let the other children take
care of that one yeah what's this shirt
I'm showing you guys first what is this
Oh what is that oh is that Pat that's
Borderlands claptrap says well done
minion Oh Borderlands you know I've
played so many a Borderlands and I bet
you guys have too handsome jack
some Jack collection gosh well you know
I'm gonna actually give this away to
some what's your size shirt uh medium
you let me down pat looks like Greg is
gonna be wearing some Borderlands around
600 I do own Borderlands I just haven't
played yet but I do own it yeah that's
right this is just to get you hyped for
the game this gets you excited for I'm
excited for it yeah alright there
finally promoting it the next t-shirt is
actual fallout fallout nuka-cola red
power
oh cool the statute let's open this was
that gaming Brandon yeah you gotta get
loot gaming in my rice is a service see
it Pat's an actual gamer and that makes
a big difference i won
- oh man I said in the Box I'm going to
this little peak as everyone knows Greg
everybody has fallen has a cockney
accent so that was extremely accurate to
the games he doesn't know I know doesn't
live jokes God hey kit oh another one
that is that a statue or is that coffee
mug tesselecta reg a coffee mug you know
if we opened the one for fallout we
should open this one anyway of course
I'm assuming it's also Borderlands Oh
smug great game love that game can't
wait last of us is what got me back
enjoy gaming I caught up on gaming last
year not fully cob obvious there's a lot
of video it's a lot of hours but last
February I started The Last of Us I'm
playing video games since and it's
because of this game well my favorites
for sure I love love this game cannot
wait philosophers two main reason I
wanted ps4 read that to you and last -
didn't didn't have it friend brought it
over we played the first 15 minutes and
we were both like in tears
oh the ps3 got it played it cried again
I would play it again it's like a movie
and the second one's the Dark Knight why
don't we just put the game arrow home
let's just do a whole video review of
beginning man guys so chapter one
universe apocalypse we have like you
know this family dynamic we got one more
item one more okay yeah we just do it
let's do what is it alright we got no
way no way no way this is from rage -
I've seen the trailer for it and inhale
so there's a little sign right here this
is cool something that we're going like
John's bedroom door you know it is that
a buck adore thing like where'd you hang
that I don't know it looks like it
should be a license plate or oh it's
like a sign the world would you say
we're pulling you over
why cuz it's a speed up it's also not
legal at all no registration doesn't
matter
I am London now on these things that
matters is you're in the hey I got
Borderlands might not have gotten rage
all right so we got one more thing I've
gotten here it was like not a t-shirt
mug statue and or metal object is a
poster a poster with a pig polish two
innocent one that's like getting a plain
bagel and finding out that it's an
everything bagel loot gaming Apokolips
will show a little photo that matt
mattox s alright so here's a little
poster here
Oh poster you put the little statue like
right in front of it yeah so it's like a
little comparisons have you played
fallout
I've played half of fallout 3 wasn't
into it gotta say gotta say more of a
Skyrim fella myself
that's follow 76 my bad so we can both
admit we're both to blame or lose but
either way we're both on the same plane
amen to that sister
have we got a second box of speed
through up ahead since the next I have
the sequel to loot box one yeah that one
what dark box - night I heard that this
is the treasure theme ok treasure
treasure if there is a t-shirt or any
pesticide lats buddy let's give you the
first item it is
who's the tough it's a nicely packed box
Luke gaming man he'd really have sent
Tom why you out with the boys
am i a fan of the economy look at that
emerald right here that's beautiful
that's beautiful a lot yeah all right
Sol's card wall like the Sun I have many
a Dark Souls in my possession it goes in
your wallet so if you're like it's a
card one I don't need a wallet like if
you yeah if if you want like your cards
and everything to be like really on
display so a thief can easily walk by
you and just snatching it you also gonna
show people that like you're not a pleb
that you've played big boy games there
no next item so this is cool it's not a
shirt but it's a clothing related object
and I can't tell if it's off screen so
reveal Oh
elder scrolls Elder Scrolls died you
that you fake fan dude I spent eight
hours on my hair I'm sorry ah did you
really know that's a long time no real
drama do you want the Hat sure this is a
real moment payment for being on the
regions right there Elmo
yeah he was just not gonna call the
police for me breaking in this is way
better than so much cool right there you
go buddy
[Laughter]
all right next item I don't have enough
mugs I'll tell you why I need to take a
photo of this up close because you guys
can't see you guys this looks like a
black mother right don't you see the
intricate all the team when it doesn't
automatically well gets for you guys
Greg's lost it again it's actually
intricate like artwork so zoom in kids
see that also I'll take a photo all
right he's got a shirt do you want a
shirt with a photo on it because
howdy-doo I got something for you I can
tell the fire that is Laura crawl oh man
the two bright hot she's got a shadow
that's for sure who lauren cohan could
have played her yeah like a year ago
hey now she's new all know she's got
she's got the hit TV series that
everyone's gonna watch whiskey Cavalier
dude which is gonna overtake the Tomb
Raider franchise and it's gonna be like
thank God she left the walking dead
because or whiskey Cavalier this generic
cuz you know she is a female support did
when male when I am at a family dinner
and my mom brings up the general topic
that everyone talks about whiskey
Cavalier I'm like have you heard about
the hit new lauren cohan show and she's
like tell me more I would have known
about this by now I'm surprised I did
not hear well I do invite you to my
family gatherings great so well do you
could have known it's all the way in
Glendale which is a 15 minutes ride that
I don't want alright shadow of the Tomb
Raider I have actually played this the
walkthrough footage on YouTube when I
had to prepare for the zoom Raider game
I played through the first one half of
the second one and didn't bother with
the third so I'm informed I'll tell you
this though I thought Tomb Raider was a
highly underrated video game adaptation
movie with Alicia vikander it's a BAM
I'm excited wear this shirt and my
sister is a big steam Raiders fan so she
will not fit I meant in the general
sense of be disappointed that you have
the shirt that she would want Greg I
should have went there damn it yeah guys
get your loot gaming box today Pat the
Canadian thanks for being here you hope
filmmaker hey if there's one thing I can
do its present things such as films and
or objects from loot gaming you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and like I said
go get a loot gaming box a day be the
first one from the real rejects
very good very good I'm here for
marketing